Cyril Ramaphosa has been sworn in as
president of South Africa after being
returned to office in elections earlier
this month from a poza has promised a
new dawn for South Africa the country
suffers from high crime slumping
economic growth and high unemployment
his presidency follows a corruption
scandal that brought down his
predecessor the inauguration took place
in a stadium and Pretoria with regional
leaders in attendance for more on this
let's now bring in our correspondent
alien creature joins us from Cape Town
oddly an after being sworn in Ramaphosa
had a message for the people in South
Africa What did he say well he mainly
tried to spread optimism and hope for
the audience we're in this Stadium
remember more than 6 million of young
voters did not even registered although
they were eligible to vote in this
election so there's a lot of
frustrations especially amongst young
people and our Mufasa tried to address
them try to tell them well we're still
walking very hard to make this nation a
better place he promised that he's
trying everything to end poverty in this
country within a generation but he also
did not only try to spread optimism for
the people of South Africa you also used
the opportunity that more than 20
African heads of states were there to
address African issues for example he
said that he wants a free trade area
between Cape Town and Cairo and this is
something new to hear from him because
it was the biggest two economies in
Africa Nigeria and South Africa that
have been blocking such a free trade
zone in the last year so this might be a
new direction the fight against
corruption was an essential part of Rahm
opposes campaign rhetoric and he
addressed the issue in his inaugural
speech let's have a listen our people
have watched some of those in whom they
had invested their trust have
surrendered to the temptation of power
and riches the challenges that our
country face
are huge and they are real but they are
not insurmountable Cyril Ramaphosa
talking there earlier today Adrienne
will he be able to clean up his parties
his party's reputation that is the big
question here will he really be able to
walk his talk many people have their
doubts because the ANC has been in power
for 25 years and it moved from a
liberation movement into a party that
many people here see that has a lot of
criminal elements a lot of people who
try to enrich themselves in the past
remember during the time of a former
President Jacob Zuma
corruption was rampant in all levels of
governance and when the new president
Rama Pusa took over more than a year ago
he promised to end that he promised to
also go after people in his very own
country and he emphasized this again
today in his own operation speech that
he wants to free this country of
corruption but the key question is will
he really go against his own people will
he really walk his talk or is it's just
the same things that we've hit in the
past from other heads of states and in
the country so this is what South
Africans are really keenly waiting for
to see if you will take action and very
soon we will actually see first results
because he will advance his cabinet in
the next days are seeing live pictures
of the inauguration there again Rama
poses said that huge challenges await
which ones is he likely to tackle first
absolutely I mean the big issue when you
talk to young people here is the economy
and unemployment more than every second
person in South Africa is unemployed and
when you talk to people here this is the
answer you get all the time the
president needs to fix the economy it
has been growing slower than the
population and that clearly is a problem
so he has to walk on that and he
promised that this is going to be his
priority again please joining us from
Cape Town thank you very much